foreign
Sudanese are fleeing from what they
describe as a living nightmare many are
waiting at the border to cross into
Egypt the journey will be long cramped
and hot
we can withstand anything we manage the
sound of gunfire so we can withstand the
heat of a closed truck this is easy
in the city of wadihalfa beds can be
rented for five dollars a day that's a
lot for families who have nothing
amenity Jani and her daughters came here
from Khartoum
we left our homes with nothing and now
we're staying here because Sudan has
been destroyed
this man says he's been living in a park
for days and has run out of his diabetes
medication
I need to take my insulin today is the
third day that I haven't taken insulin I
have no money I lift all my money and my
job
as the humanitarian situation
deteriorates the need for Aid increases
the number of people internally
displaced in Sudan has more than doubled
in the last week according to data
that's been collected by the
International Organization for
migrations displacement tracking Matrix
now more than 700 000 people are now
internally displaced by the fighting
which began on the 15th of April lack of
funds is keeping many of those here in
Khartoum from leaving others say they're
staying to protect their homes from
robberies and looting which has
increased since the fighting started
it's a difficult Choice as civilians are
at risk of being caught in the crossfire
between the two wearing sides dogs in
Jeddah between Sudan's Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces are
aimed at agreeing on humanitarian
corridors but after a series of failed
ceasefires many Sudanese aren't prepared
to wait around Heber Morgan Al Jazeera
Khartoum